hey youtubers is Charlie arrow is back
and it followed up on all the
cliffhangers from the end of last season
as well as introducing a new DC Comics
villain from Canon in addition to that
we also have information on the next
five episodes all the way through the
first appearance of Ra's al Ghul's
daughter be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be an amazing
second half of the season what I'm gonna
do in this video is my top 5 moments
then I'll do my review like usual but
then I'm gonna do a breakdown of some of
the references to the comic books as
well as the titles for those next couple
of episodes so here we go number 5
Roy powers up he's just starting to show
the effects of the serum but Stephen
Amell has been posting pictures of
Oliver training him which is gonna be so
much fun to watch I think they made him
angry at the beginning of the episode
just to make his path to super hero a
little more ambiguous in the comic books
the character has a really bad drug
habit before he cleaned up and joined
the Justice League they're just kind of
jumping back and forth between Roy's
experience on the mirakuru serum and how
he deals with it and how Slade deals
with it back on the island
speaking of which number four slade goes
nanners I love Manu Bennett he's so
awesome - Slade so watching him slowly
lose his over the next couple of
episodes is gonna be amazing you can
just tell that he's going to be the one
to kill Ivo and it's gonna be disgusting
in the best possible way obviously the
final falling out between him and Oliver
is going to be you know whenever he
loses that eye because we saw him in
present day and he had the eyepatch on
so at some point that's going to happen
number three Oliver and Felicity I'm
talking about their last scene when
Oliver finally admits to how much he
needs her the show has made a joke of
Felicity's role as overworked secretary
for a long time so it was really nice to
see Oliver finally get real with her
there was a moment before Barry Allen's
episode where they almost had this kiss
and Oliver explained that he had to keep
his distance from the people that he
cares about most so for all the olicity
shippers out there the only place
they'll be hooking up this year will be
on your tumblr I do kind of wonder
though if the director in each episode
explains them you know whatever you're
in a scene and there's just the two of
you you should always be just about to
kiss I just love the way they shoot
their scenes is so funny
number two flash dreams that's a good
question what does the flash dream about
I'm wondering if they're going to wake
him up at the beginning of his TV show
pilot episode they implied that Felicity
would be going back and forth
to see him on a regular basis I think
it's more to keep the character in
people's minds you know into the air the
pilot episode but it's also possible the
Felicity could be the through line
between these two series and my number
one moment the Whedon verse crossover I
always love when I see Whedon actors on
other genre shows the shrapnel character
mostly appeared in The Outsiders and
Doom Patrol comics and he didn't really
have a big backstory but I did like that
they made him a toymaker in this episode
he didn't get a lot of scenes just
because the brother Bloods storyline got
so much screen time but I'm interested
to see if he shows up later in the show
as part of the Suicide Squad I would say
that almost every mid-level villain on
arrow that does not die at the end of
the episode is a good candidate for the
Suicide Squad let me know what your
favorite moment was in the comments
below you know wasn't watching Slade go
nanners was it seeing Sean Maher guest
star here are actually a few of the
comic book references that you may have
missed though first off the flash on the
show he's gonna come up but in the comic
books after he was struck by the Speed
Force he recovered immediately they also
kind of implied that Felicity is gonna
be featured on both shows it's possible
that she could either be physically
featured in star on both shows or it
could just be that their relationship is
the through line and Barry will mention
Felicity and Felicity will just mention
Barry - when Oliver's chasing shrapnel
he passes by a Pemberton Street sign in
the comic books Sylvester Pemberton was
sky man he was mostly part of the
Justice Society and infinity
Incorporated series later the character
ended up getting killed by Solomon
Grundy so a nice hat tip there maybe
that street sign is a memorial three
detective Lance's callsign is 52 that's
a reference to DC's 52 miniseries for
brother blood killed his parents in the
comic books - obviously on the show his
mother's still alive number five the
movement the group shrapnel is a part of
in the episode is also an
anti-establishment organization in DC's
52 miniseries six Sebastian is the devil
in the comic books he's associated with
a satanic cult and he's linked with the
demon Trigon who's also a villain of Roy
Harper's in the Teen Titan comics
overall I liked the episode it was a bit
of a slow burn though I'm not a big fan
of the brother flood storyline and that
took up most of the plot I did really
like the Superman Lex Luthor vibe that
Oliver and brother blood were giving off
though there was a period on Smallville
when Clark and Lex were still friends
and you could see that Lex was deceiving
him eventually he did learn the truth
about him being a villain which is
obviously gonna happen on arrow as well
too fortunately Oliver will probably end
up learning the truth about
in the next episode so here are the
titles of those episodes episode 11 is
called blind spot Oliver and Laurel
investigates Sebastian blood and this is
probably when he learns he's the man in
the mask episode 12 is called tremors
Oliver will start training Roy I sure
hope he insured the arrow cave because I
think it's gonna get a little smashy
episode 13 is called heir to the demon
and it's gonna be the first appearance
of Nyssa al Ghul episode 14 is called
time of death in episode 15 is called
the promise we don't know a lot about
those episodes but be sure to subscribe
to get everything
arrow is on fire this year I really
personally cannot wait to see Slade in
full on Deathstroke here that is gonna
be awesome
I also totally want to give a shout out
to Manu Bennett he shared my top 10
moments video on his Twitter thank you
so much you can actually click here to
watch that video right now and you can
click here to watch my top 10
predictions for the second half of the
season thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you